as the delta variant holds its grip on
the nation and clark county the southern
nevada health district is opening new
testing kiosks around the valley hector
mejia live in the east side near eastern
the 95 explaining how the new testing
sites work
hector
well these kiosks are designed to limit
contact between staff and people who are
here to get a test once you're done with
the test you hand it over to someone
who's behind a plexiglas window at the
testing site right behind us and it all
happens outdoors we are at the east las
vegas community center by eastern and
the 95 but these kiosks are also at the
cambridge parkdale and walnut recreation
centers plus the alexander library and
this is bringing more options to people
in this neighborhood especially those
who are not able to make appointments
online it offers free testing to
walk-ups and people who set up an
appointment through the southern nevada
health district's website it'll stay
open for the next six to eight weeks
mondays through fridays from noon to 6
pm
councilwoman olivia diaz represents this
award she also sits on the board of the
southern nevada health district and she
recommends everyone to get tested even
if you are fully vaccinated if you start
to feel sick
there can be breakthrough cases and the
symptoms are milder so i would say out
of an abundance of caution if you're
feeling symptoms that feel like a flu
just come and get tested it may be
coveted and you just don't want to be a
carrier
according to the cdc's website the level
of covet transmission here in clark
county remains high the councilwoman
says the east side has been
disproportionately affected by the virus
this kiosk will help front line workers
who get exposed to positive cases and
need to get tested and now with the
schools open this is also going to help
those students who may get exposed while
they're in the classroom and need a
negative test before returning back to
class reporting on the east side hector
mejia 8 news now